in development management Committee of
Trafford Council I'm the chair of the
committee my name is councilor Ben
Hartley on my immediate right is the
vice chair of the committee councilor
Barry Wayne Stanley and to Alden Wright
are officers from the council who are
members of the planning legal team and
the highways team
the further down on the tables on on the
left and right are members of the
committee who are all elected members of
the council
and I'll introduce those people by name
oh okay
can you hear me now yeah okay sorry uh
okay let me start again sorry my name's
um councilor Ben Hartley I'm the chair
of the committee councilor Barry win
Stanley is on my immediate right he's
the vice chair of the committee and then
on our left and right our offices from
the council from the planning highways
and legal team and then down the tables
to the side are members of the committee
who are all elected councilors and I'll
introduce those members by name when
they wish to speak on an item this
meeting is being recorded and it's been
live streamed on the council's YouTube
site and a recording of the meeting will
be available for for a Time afterwards
can I just check whether everyone here
wishes to film any part of the meeting
please no okay
will proceed with their agenda then so
first of all we'll just note the
attendancies and um apologies for
absence we haven't had any apologies for
absence but we are a reduced committee
so
um members will know that a number of
councilors
um either stood down or did not retain
their uh seats at the local elections
and so they're no longer members of the
committee and we can't have substitutes
for those members because they're not
actually members of the committee
anymore so we're reducing numbers for
for this meeting
only item number two is uh Declarations
of Interest so it's members to give
notice of any personal or prejudicial
interest in the nature of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the adopted code of
conduct are there any members looking to
make any declarations at this time
no okay item number three is the minutes
of the last meeting so it's to receive
and have agreed approve as a correct
record the minutes of the last meeting
on the 13th of April uh 2023. uh I
wasn't here for that meeting so I'm just
looking to members to propose happy
Council Thomas and councilman Stanley is
happy to Second out so we'll approve
those as an accurate record of the of
the last meeting item number four is
questions from members of the public so
we have a maximum of 50 minutes which is
allocated to public questions submitted
to democratic Services by 4 pm on the
Working Day prior to the meeting and the
questions that we can deal with must be
within the remit of the committee or be
relevant to items appearing on the
agenda and they'll be submitted in the
order they were received we haven't had
any questions uh from members of the
public for this meeting item number five
is the additional information report
um so it's to consider the report from
the head of Planning and Development
um it's been tabled at this meetings so
copies are available and it's been
emailed out to members of the committee
earlier on today
item number six is applications for
permission to develop
um the first application that will we
will consider is application number one
one zero two zero six which is 22A Hope
Road and uh we'll start off with a
presentation from Ms Milner thank you
thank you chair
this application relates to a two-story
detached property in a residential area
of sale in close proximity to sail Town
Center
the application proposes the widening of
the existing driveway direction of new
boundary treatment and a drop curb
the application is reported to the
planning committee as it has received
more than six representations contrary
to the officer recommendation and an
objection from local War counselor
councilor Brotherton
objections receive a detail within the
officer report and the additional
information report and include matters
of design amenity highways and impact on
people with protected characteristics
as detailed within the committee report
and the additional information report
the scheme has been amended
significantly to ensure so it appears
most subservient and appropriate
Revelation to the existing dwelling and
surrounding setting
as a result
given the scale design and context of
The Proposal it is considered acceptable
and would have an improvement to the
existing driveway Arrangements in
regards to highway safety
representations have been received
representations have considered have
been considered an action taken to
minimize the impact of The Proposal it
is therefore considered that whilst The
Proposal would have an impact some
impact on residents this would be an
acceptable impact on all residents
including those with protected
characteristics
as such the proposal is considered to
Accord with the development plan for
Trafford and the mppf and as such is
recommended for approval
subject to the conditions outlined
within the committee report thank you
[Music]
thank you Miss Miller is Mr Haywood here
do you want to come and have a seat just
opposite me
um so at this point I'm going to propose
that I committed it we move into a
private session and that we had closed
the meeting to the public I think
the reasons for that are clear from the
information that you've had so can I
just check that members are happy to
move that resolution yeah okay so so at
that point we'll move into private
session so we'll stop the YouTube
recording if we could and
Mr Hayward are you content for the